they say that if March comes in like a
lion it goes out like a lamb but much
roar like a lion all the way through
starting off strong with South Park a
stick of truth and continuing through
great games like in from the second son
and tower fall it wasn't just Cartman's
farts that blew us away paths tone metal
gear solid ground zeroes and a new
walking dead episode all managed to
impress us in their various ways but
there were two games that managed to
stand on the backs of these quality
games and duke it out for superiority
indeed much was ultimately about to
juggernauts titanfall and dark souls 2
sorry titanfall we love you and have a
special place in our hearts but dark
souls 2 demanded our attention more than
any other game this month if Dark Souls
2 were your significant other you need
relationship counselling this kind of
codependence might not always be healthy
but dark souls 2 insists on nothing less
than your full focus it's not a survival
horror game in the normal sense but few
games can make you this afraid to peer
around the corner while simultaneously
curious as to what awaits you there Dark
Souls 2 is loaded with secrets and
surprises and it's just so cruel but
it's such a beautiful cruelty Dark Souls
2 is an impressive game and game sports
game of the month we'll march 2014
praise the Sun